une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le
podcasts
[Musique]
quand même un bon rythme c'est vraiment
le fun de voir les nouveaux projets qui
naissent ici puis si vous voulez lancer
votre propre projet ou amener une
Project vous avez
[Musique]
oserais-je dire à un autre niveau
vous pouvez louer nos espaces aller voir
pour plus d'informations au studio sf.ca
cette semaine dans cette semaine c'est
un grand plaisir d'avoir à nouveau le
grand retour de Jean-Martin Ossant au
podcast un des invités que j'avais
préféré recevoir
plus de 3 ans on avait reçu à l'époque
en tant que
figure politique du Québec et maintenant
en fait cette économiste de formation il
travaille comme économiste alors on leur
su proposer plein de questions sur qui
se passe en ce moment dans l'économie
parce qu'on entend toutes sortes
d'affaires puis on vit plusieurs
affaires le coût du pétrole de bon sang
les coups de l'immobilier qui a pas de
bon sang les coins qui chutent
la guerre en Ukraine la pandémie toutes
les effets de ça comprendre c'est quoi
l'inflation c'est quoi une récession
c'est quoi une stagnation c'est quoi une
dépression ça n'a pas parlé par exemple
on a vraiment des mystifier sauf
[Musique]
c'était vraiment super un gobrillant un
god drôle un gars fascinant moi je
pourrais l'écouter parler pendant des
décennies alors
bonne écoute
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par auchlag le fournisseur officiel de
boissons alcoolisée et non alcoolisé du
studio SF sauf que ça veut dire c'est
pointer ici pour louer le studio vous
avez des invités notre fridge est à vous
notre frère il est plein d'achat faites
vous l'ouvrez puis vous avez tous les
produits de Schlag qu'on a ici c'est
gratuit c'est à faire puis nous
évidemment comme vous allez pouvoir le
constater pendant le podcast aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on boit pendant les podcasts
une petite sortie de un podcast toujours
agréable moi justement vous allez voir
dans le podcast que l'on vient de
terminer de le tourner je fais ma
deuxième celle-ci ça m'a rafraîchit
dans le palais tout le long du podcast
j'ai adoré ça les amis les Celtes hier
j'ai goûté parce que oui j'ai recommencé
à boire un petit peu tranquillement
parce que j'étais un meilleur place dans
ma tête dans mon cœur mais j'ai goûté la
la à la vodka puis je pense j'ai pris
exactement cela framboise honnêtement et
absolument incroyable puis leur nouvelle
gamme de ceinture à votre cas sont
disponibles dans les SEQ sinon les
autres les autres c'est le seul vous
pouvez les trouver dans les dépanneurs
les circuits les épiceries sinon toutes
les autres de bières les bières sans
alcool il est vraiment pour tous les
goûts ouais vraiment les jeans des jeans
toutes les stars c'est vraiment de la
bombe puis on les remercie puis vous
testez leurs produits vous allez capoter
merci
[Musique]
le podcast
c'est les meilleurs produits d'entretien
pour en dessous de la ceinture mais
aussi pour le corps moi nous moi je dois
parler au jeu on est pas on n'est pas
nous encore ok
mais moi c'est mes produits préférés je
capote sur mainscape j'utilise leur body
wash qui est hydratant j'utilise leurs
deux leur shampoing qu'on revitalisant
deux en un j'utilise ça littéralement à
tous les jours c'est les meilleurs
produits j'ai testé j'ai testé plein la
FAP moi vous savez j'ai mangé pendant
vraiment longtemps ma peau est sèche
encore à ce jour je nage souvent trois
fois par semaine chaque fois que je sors
de la piscine ma peau est sèche à cause
du chlore le bas des wattes en Hydra
c'est de l'absolu bombe
parce que moi la ma méthode préférée de
trimage de bijoux de famille c'est ça
qui est là c'est le petit rasoir
men'scape autre chose
il va vraiment bien être incroyable de
plusieurs lames qui vient avec ceux qui
est facile et malléable
c'est vraiment de la bombe sinon si
jamais vous demandez comment par où
commencer ou qu'est-ce que je peux
acheter qui est un package qui va avoir
mettons tout ce que j'ai besoin
là-dedans
[Musique]
il y a tout ce que tu as besoin il y a
le lendemain qui est le trimeur qui est
le si vous voulez pas avoir l'air d'un
petit bébé comme double
Walker pour les narines il y a le body
wash shampoing il y a le déodorant il y
a le déodorant pour bijou de famille
[Musique]
on a un code promo pour vous autres qui
est sans filtre 20 % de rabais je suis
pas une gratuit c'est un code promo qui
est une scène c'est une promo fête qui
est une scène tout ça c'est de la bombe
c'est un produit qu'on adore puis ça
fait longtemps que qui encourage de
santé de podcast ils ont été là
malgré les vagues et le vent puis il y a
toujours rester avec nous fait que
encourageait puis tu sais un code promo
qui sache que ça vient nous autres fait
que merci ça gagne merci vous êtes bon
podcast
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est parti salut Jean Martin comment
salut
ça fait quand même longtemps presque 3
ans plus que 3 ans
on était pas on avait aucune idée de
même le début de ce qu'on allait vivre
le
enveloppe trois ans
on connaît la pandémie existait pas du
tout là on dirait que ce monde-là est
comme un monde qui n'existe plus dans ma
tête
à jamais il est modifié en tout cas il y
a des choses qui vont rester de sport
des choses qui vont venir un peu comme
elle d'avant mais en fait la pandémie a
pas créé des nouvelles tendances je
trouve qu'elle a accéléré ce qui était
déjà là c'est le télétravail le fait
consommer à la maison de faire venir les
achats sur le web et tout ça ça accéléré
des tendances qui étaient déjà là mais
qui aurait peut-être pris 10-15 ans à
s'installer dans l'économie disons ça a
pris cinq semaines c'est ça
c'est une première aussi de fermer
volontairement une économie inutilement
dit vous arrêtez vous restez chez vous
c'est déjà vu pour ça que il y a rien
qui est allé comme les économistes ou
les analyses prédisaient
puis justement quand on avait reçu en
fait à l'époque on avait reçu
Jean-Martin à sable plus l'homme
politique quand on veut tandis
qu'aujourd'hui on te reçoit en tant que
économiste parce que tu es retourné
travailler dans ce domaine-là
parce que justement ce moment moi j'ai
jamais été quelqu'un mettons qui suivait
activement l'économie mais quand ça
touche vraiment directement c'est ça
il a explosé puis que tu commences à
penser à qui je veux tu
m'acheter une maison maintenant les prix
explosent aussi là t'as pas le choix de
commencer à suivre ça un peu plus
activement intéressé tu racontes que tu
as pas le choix de t'y intéresser parce
que l'économie c'est ta vie de tous les
jours exactement
que quand c'est pas
concret ça reste vraiment flou à moins
que tu t'y intéresses beaucoup aussi
puis pour monsieur madame tout le monde
c'est quand même moi je me rappelle
quand il y a eu le Castel la pandémie a
commencé puis que c'est on ferme
l'économie puis j'entendais ça comme si
c'était la pérateur au monde mais pour
moi que je me disais mais là c'est
toujours bien moins pire que évidemment
perdre des vies puis il me semble c'est
pas si grave puis après ça tu réalises
que ok non il peut avoir un impact
majeur sur la vie de beaucoup de monde
je pense qu'il y a un impact plus que
majeur sur la santé mentale globale des
populations partout dans le monde pas
juste au Québec mais ça je pense que les
gens qui étaient un peu fragiles ont
vraiment trouvé ça très très dur puis la
plupart des gens sont fragiles d'une
façon d'une heure donc il y a personne
qui est sorti de là Inde je pense
maintenant
le stress l'anxiété causer justement par
le stress financier de dû à la pandémie
ou dû à tout ce qui arrive en ce moment
qui fait que c'est extrêmement difficile
parce que c'est c'est pas une question
une question de santé finalement
de style de vie il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui ont changé de carrière
pendant après la pandémie souvent
volontairement mais parfois parce qu'il
va pas trop le choix parce que
l'économie aussi c'est replacé un peu
donc il y a personne qui est sorti de là
en disant qu'il s'est rien passé mais
deux dernières années là ça c'est cela
ouais en ce moment on parle beaucoup de
récession puis moi je vois je vois
avouer vraiment être nul à chier dans
comme tout ce qui est des connaissances
d'économie je pense avec le code
beaucoup de nos auditeurs qu'on voit on
entend parler de ça justement en éco
lointain puis on n'est pas du genre
nécessairement aller faire des des Dave
dans des articles de cette bien
comprendre que ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qui se passe en ce moment
on a le sac d'une
période euphorique dans l'économie
c'était quand la pandémie est arrivé il
y a eu le choc d'une fermeture de bains
dépend d'économie ça c'était horrible
pour bien des gens mais en même temps
les gouvernements partout dans le monde
ont injecté pas des millions pas des
milliards des milliers de milliard dans
l'économie pour aider les particuliers
les entreprises et ça ça fait en sorte
que il y avait de la trop d'argent dans
le système puis tu peux pas te sortir de
ça économiquement sans avoir des petites
dégradigures là puis là on le voit ce
que ça a donné ça a donné de l'inflation
parce que quand il y a trop d'argent
évidemment ça met la pression à la
hausse sur les prix et en plus les
chaînes les chaînes de production la
chaîne de valeur quand un produit fini
au Québec il y a peut-être 8 entreprises
dans 6 pays différents qui ont contribué
à construire ça toutes ces chaînes là
ont été perturbées par la pandémie
beaucoup le sont encore sa peine
pression à la hausse sur les prix aussi
va s'écrit de la rareté parce que un
manque de certaines ressources donc tout
ça fait en sorte qu'on vit les
contrecoups de la période pandémique là
avec l'argent qui était aussi gratuit
les taux d'intérêt étaient à zéro même
en Europe au Japon il était négatif
plutôt d'intérêt on payait les gens pour
emprunter donc ça c'est quand l'économie
va vraiment mal et donc ce fait le fait
que l'argent était gratuit pendant trop
longtemps puis que l'inflation arrive
les banques centrales doivent augmenter
les taux d'intérêt pour ralentir
l'économie parce que l'inflation est
et le défi des banques centrales on
entend souvent parler de la Réserve
fédérale aux États-Unis et puis la
Banque du Canada pardon puis la Banque
centrale européenne le défi c'est de
ralentir l'économie sans la mettre en
récession c'est ça le gros débat en ce
moment si on augmente les taux trop vite
il risque de créer une récession sauf
qu'ils ont pas le choix d'augmenter les
taux parce que l'inflation pour une
économie c'est en CRS permanente c'est
pire qu'une récession parce qu'il se
passe plus grand chose qu'un trou
d'inflation et donc les pays comme
l'Argentine là qui ont 60 70 %
d'inflation c'est la crise totale tu
peux dire l'argent ton argent c'est fou
et plus personne qui investit dans rien
et puis personne qui fait rien parce que
justement l'un de mes matins depuis la
même valeur que tu pensais dans le
projet la veille et donc les banques
centrales n'ont pas le choix d'augmenter
les taux d'intérêt pour tuer cette
inflation là mais ça ça a des
conséquences énormes ça va ralentir
l'économie il faut qu'il essaie de le
faire sans créer une récession une des
conséquences majeures c'est les
hypothèques évidemment tous ceux qui ont
acheté une maison dans le haut du cycle
immobilier qu'on connaît là qui était
qui ont calculé juste dans leur dans
leur budget le les taux d'intérêt va
monter de quelques points de
pourcentages ça peut mener à des clés
qui retournent à la banque on espère que
non parce qu'en 2008 la crise avait été
causée par ça par une crise immobilière
aux États-Unis la grande différence
c'est qu'en ce moment il y a moins de
près non solvable ou un solvable qui en
avait en 2008 il y avait une il y avait
eu un abus incroyable aux États-Unis de
près qui était pas de gens qui avaient
des prêts qui pouvaient plus payer que
là il y avait plus rien au départ il y a
placé les prix ninjas l'acronyme c'était
nowhen nojob Noa 7 ninja donc
l'hypothèse c'était que la maison va
vouloir plus cher dans un mois donc si
le golf a faillite la banque prend la
maison peut largement plus cher que le
prêter sauf que m'ont donné les
freestyle ou même se mettent à descendre
puis c'est là que ça fait une pyramide
immobilière le Canada la
Nouvelle-Zélande et certains pays qui
ont été vraiment
identifiés comme étant des marchés trop
trop chaud trop chaud en ce moment le
Canada est devant les marchés les plus
les plus trop les plus trop actifs
[Musique]
je suis parti de ceux qui pensent que
l'immobilier devrait pas être un secteur
de spéculation une maison c'est pour
vivre c'est pour habiter là pour avoir
un foyer la fameuse périmée de Maslow là
dans les besoins là-bas dans le logement
c'est peut-être le deuxième et c'est
dans les facteurs de base puis en ce
moment c'est devenu le flipping de
maison et tout ça les gens achètent pour
revendre un mois après à 100000 de
profit et quelque chose de malsain
là-dedans moi je si j'étais en position
de décider les enfants
pour visiter puis tout le monde fait un
bide mais c'est l'aveugle oui exactement
tu sais pas ce que l'autre maintenant
que la maison est à 500000 puis toi tu
as vu vraiment
c'est ça alors que peut-être que le
deuxième plus élevé est à 537 mais tu
sais pas moi je mettrai ça public donc
ouvert de transparent puis c'est celui
qui avait vraiment le plus qui va vider
le plus haut simplement et puis tu vas
éviter des des surchauffes incroyables
qu'on a vu récemment c'est c'est
vraiment causé par l'opacité des offres
d'achat est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
raisons que ça à l'immobilier la
pandémie a été parce que les gens qui se
disaient m'installe à la maison je vais
faire du travail même après la pandémie
il voulait plus grand ou plus loin du
travail pour être en nature ou je sais
pourquoi donc
ça amené une offre additionnelle une
demande additionnelle pour une offre qui
était assez fixée statique là on va des
grues un peu partout à Montréal qui
construisent mais quand même la demande
[Musique]
en fait les loyers ont suivi un peu plus
lentement heureusement pour les
locataires sauf quand il y en a un qui
quittent le propriétaire peut m'aider à
faire
encore une fois c'est que la demande
surpassait beaucoup là et donc ça c'est
une loi de base en économie les sciences
économiques se trompent souvent dans
bien des hypothèses ça c'est une loi
assez naturel plus les gens veulent plus
le prix peut être élevé et puis moins
les gens veulent mais moi le prix va
être élevé puis à l'inverse plus tu en
as si tu noms de marché d'un produit tu
peux pas le vendre aussi cher que c'est
une rareté donc tout ça combiné faisant
ça que on a eu connu un décès immobilier
les plus surchauffés de mon vivant
économique est-ce que c'est parce que
pour ceux que sont propriétaires
l'augmentation de la valeur des
propriétés c'est une bonne nouvelle si
on veut tandis que pour quelqu'un comme
moi qui l'ai pas puis qui aimerait un
jour
moi une bonne nouvelle mais attends mais
d'un point de vue économique est-ce que
c'est est-ce que ça donne ce que c'est
une preuve de
une économie qui est en santé ou pas
vraiment mais ça dépend des valeurs en
fait des pays très très riches où le
taux de propriétaire est très bas en
Allemagne la majorité des gens sont
locataires c'est un pays riche on peut
pas dire l'inverse donc ça dépend des
aspirations de chacun il y en a beaucoup
qui veulent être propriétaire il y en a
d'autres moi ça me dérange pas pour être
propriétaire en ce moment je suis
locataire j'ai déjà été propriétaire en
ce moment j'ai un loyer puis tu sais ça
vient avec certains
devoir être propriétaire
de l'aménagement tout ça il y a des
avantages d'être locataires ceci dit
c'est quand même bien que les gens qui
veuillent avoir accès à une première
accès à la propriété que ce soit facile
en ce moment avec les prix actuels il y
a plein de familles qui misaient
là-dessus et qui pourront plus surtout
avec les taux qui montent et les prêts
qui viennent de plus en plus cher les
empereurs donc l'accession à la
propriété à ce moment ce sera pas très
facile comme il était peut-être quand
l'argent était gratuit quand il y avait
eu moins de surchauffe c'est des années
consécutives de 20% de hausse ça laisse
des marques
parce que moi personnellement je sais
que
la valeur de l'immobilier et puis comme
c'est pas c'est impossible pour moi de
rentrer sur le marché mais donc c'est
avec le marché actuel puis alors que on
recule le développement si longtemps
quelqu'un qui rentre à sa trentaine qui
avait probablement un salaire comme le
mien devait être capable de rentrer sur
le marché immobilier assez simplement ça
dépend des quartiers aussi il y a des
quartiers c'est devenu juste plusieurs
personnes qui habitent une maison qui
pourrait plus se payer aujourd'hui ouais
c'est ça exactement
comme on dit en bas français de
l'acheter une période où c'était
peut-être plus abordable mais il y a
plein de gens qui sont dans une maison
qui auraient pas les moyens d'acheter en
ce moment
tant mieux pour eux parce que c'est un
investissement qui a marché mais encore
une fois moi je j'aimerais que
l'immobilier devienne plutôt le besoin
de base de se loger plutôt que d'être un
instrument de
spéculation en fait qui la spéculation
des effets juste négatifs
et des gens mouillé à moyen un peu plus
humble qui sont éloignés tout le temps
des quartiers intéressants
ça devient un peu on achète des maisons
qu'on achète des Bitcoin c'est devenu un
outil d'investissement pour bien des
gens alors que ça doit être un outil de
base pour habiter quelque part avec sa
famille ou ses amis ou tout seul si on
veut mais ça devrait pas être un outil
d'investissement comme une action ou une
obligation ou le Bitcoin justement qui
est un autre affaire on va en parler des
fois j'espère mais ça justement parce
que on entend tellement
en tout cas moi je me suis fait dire par
plein de mes amis qui ont mon âge qui
commence à avoir de l'argent et puis qui
veulent investir le plus safe c'est
l'immobilier l'immobilier c'est le plus
simple mais effectivement que une fois
que tu remets si tu mets ça tu dis ouais
c'est peut-être un investissement simple
mais c'est aussi un besoin de base qu'on
a comme tous besoin c'est vrai que je
l'avais jamais comme je l'avais jamais
opposé ces deux idées là très long terme
c'est vrai que l'immobilier va monter il
y a très longtemps comme la bourse à
très long terme c'est sur une période de
10 12 15 ans le sucre sont jeunes puis
un profil un horizon long il y a pas
d'inquiétude avec la bourse même quand
ça baisse de 10-20 % sur des grands
horizons ça monte comme l'économie ils
croient puisc mais faut arriver dans le
bon moment du cycle ceux qui disent que
l'immobilier c'est un c'est un pari
assuré 6 ans dans le haut du cycle ils
peuvent vivre plusieurs années de
stagnation avant de rentrer dans leur
argent sur 10 ans comme ceux qui ont
investi au sommet de la bulle en 2000 ça
a pris 10 ans avant de rentrer leur
action argent à portefeuille d'action
pardon mais sur des périodes de 10 ans
c'est rare que la bourse c'est pas
positive donc là on rentre dans un
ralentissement au niveau de la hausse
des prix de l'immobilier
au Québec ça peut commencer à diminuer
encore mais au Canada les prix des
propriétés ont commencé à diminuer
aux Etats-Unis aussi en fait de dernière
semaine même dernier mois il y a eu
moins de d'opérations moins de vente et
il y a des prix plus bas parce que
pendant une certaine période il y avait
moins de ventes mais les prix continuent
de monter mais là ça a commencé vraiment
à ralentir puis un indice très
inquiétant c'est que la confiance des
consommateurs qui sont faits par des
universités aux États-Unis sur la
confiance des gens puis là c'est la
lecture la plus basse à peu près depuis
la grande la grande la confiance en
l'avenir économique financier d'emploi à
leur capacité de garder le rythme de vie
donc quand la confiance est tellement
basse ça devient un peu auto-réalisateur
les gens sont pessimistes donc ils
arrêtent de consommer donc les commerces
vont moins bien donc l'économie décroît
donc ça peut vite créer la récession en
soi quand les gens ont confiance très
basse puis à ce moment la confiance est
extrêmement basse dans les sondages
économique j'ai jamais été aussi
anxieux uniquement c'est pas parce que
je fais moins d'argent qu'avant mais
mais c'est ça mais au final c'est que
mettons si je fais le même salaire que
aujourd'hui que je faisais le 3 ans ou
un peu plus
ces décisions là je dirais est-ce que
j'imagine qu'il y a beaucoup de
spéculations mais c'est pas un tableau
qui a devant toi avec des statistiques
l'autre les économistes font comme voici
les statistiques voici l'équation puis
on a le résultat c'est un peu ça
dans des équipes d'économistes très
chevelure tableau de bord tout le monde
s'entend est-ce qu'il y a plusieurs
visions de comment régler parce que
ceux qui veulent que la banque centrale
soit très prudente donc augmente les
taux plus vite et ceux qui disent qu'il
faut laisser les taux bas pour aider
l'économie puis si on parle la fête que
la plus grande banque centrale au monde
celle des États-Unis il y a pas
longtemps leur mission c'était de
contrôler l'inflation c'est dans une
cible de données disons 2% de quelque
chose pour ça et pendant la pandémie on
changeait leur mission pleine emploi
donc ça les dérangeait pas qu'il y ait
un petit peu plus d'inflation si c'était
pour créer des emplois dans l'économie
donc il laissait les taux bas et là il y
a remis la switch en bon français à
l'inflation parce que le rendu dans les
7 8 9 % c'est très inquiétant économie à
long terme donc là ils vont vraiment
monter les taux encore de façon bien
marquée des prochains mois des
prochaines rencontres qui sont et dans
ces décisions de taux là il y a
plusieurs gouverneurs régionaux dans les
réserves fédérale américaine et il y en
a parfois qui sont pas d'accord avec les
décisions c'est tout publié là les votes
qui voulaient monter de 50 ou de 25.1
qui voulait pas il y a même un graphique
qui s'appelle le dot plat c'est les
points des votes de chaque gouverneur
puis tu vois avec le temps que ça a
beaucoup varié il y a pas si longtemps
il voulait pas tant que ça augmenter les
taux d'intérêt parce qu'ils se
concentrer sur le plein emploi mais
maintenant sont pas mal tous on peut
mettre tous en direction ces
informations là qu'elles soient
publiques c'est une
ils font ça tout le temps c'est public
mais après coup parce que si tu as
publié avant ça dégage impacts sur les
portefeuilles puis les gens les
décisions financières donc c'est très
très privé mais il publie les minutes en
fait de la rencontre comme on appelle
les minutes de la fête et donc dans ces
documents là on a le détail de leur
rencontre ça donne quand même une idée
de leur sentiment sur l'économie qui
vient il révise aussi leur prévision
économique de croissance et tout ça donc
à ce moment que les alertes sont plus au
drapeau rouge sur l'inflation que de se
dire laissons les taux bas pour que
l'économie est bien là l'économie elle
roule un peu trop avec l'inflation donc
ils veulent ralentir ça
le taux d'intérêt si tu l'as donné qui
est le plus d'impact sur
l'inflation ou si on ralentit accélère
un impact sur plein de gens on peut dire
que le taux d'intérêt de la Banque
centrale c'est on peut dire que c'est la
variable centrale de l'économie en fait
parce que la bourse faut réagir à ça
toutes les autres classes actives vont
réagir à ce l'immobilier va réagir à ça
par exemple le fait que les titres
technologiques ces derniers mois ont
vraiment mangé toute une volée le Nasdaq
qui est à -30% à peu près depuis le
début de l'année que certains titres qui
ont perdu 50-60% de leur valeur dans les
technologies les titres technologiques
leur valeur est basée sur les revenus
escomptés les revenus sûr qu'on prévoit
pour ces entreprises souvent 5 10 ans
avant et quand tu fais la valeur
présente de l'action il faut que tu
utilises un taux d'intérêt pour mettre
la valeur présente plus le taux est
élevé plus la valeur est basse la valeur
présente parce que c'est une formule
mathématique au dénominateur donc si le
taux augmente une pièce dans 10 ans vaut
de moins en moins cher plus le taux
d'intérêt élevé et donc quand les taux
montent toutes les types technologiques
sont réévalués avec le nouveau taux puis
la valeur baisse donc à partir du taux
d'intérêt de la Banque centrale même les
petites technologiques du Nasdaq ou du
SNP sont affectés par ça donc vraiment
le taux d'intérêt c'est une sinon la
variable de base de l'économie donc
mettons la décision que
que les banques prennent au niveau des
taux d'intérêt en plus d'impact que des
décisions gouvernementales par exemple
en fait il y a deux politiques la
politique monétaire ça c'est les banques
centrales puis la politique fiscale ça
c'est le gouvernement qui décide par
exemple quand le gouvernement Trudeau ou
gouvernement Biden aux États-Unis a
décidé de mettre des milliards en PCU
puis en aide à tout le monde ça c'est
une politique fiscale ça aussi c'est un
grand impact sur l'économie sacré de
l'inflation aussi parce que les gens
plus d'argent
exactement puis ou les Québec le fait
aussi récemment avec le 500 dollars
tout le monde et sa soeur ou juste à
ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin mais des
élections en octobre mais bref les
politiques la politique fiscale la
politique monétaire sont deux
instruments principaux les banques
centrales c'est la politique monétaire
donc le taux d'intérêt puis la politique
fiscale c'est combien le gouvernement de
dépenses est-ce que le gouvernement
devrait même emprunter pour dépenser
plus ça c'est la politique fiscale c'est
très important aussi puis pendant la
pandémie ça a été central puis
présentement c'est ça que justement
avec ceux qui gouvernement de jongler
finalement parce que il y a des gens
que là en ce moment est monétairement
il se trouve en difficulté fait
qu'est-ce qu'on les aide si on a trop on
fait augmenter l'inflation mais sont des
passés il y a des gens qui sont dans ce
qui est un peu contradictoire c'est que
le 500 dollars qui partaient d'une
intention d'aider les gens à se battre
contre l'inflation c'est inflationniste
en soi c'est ce que les gens en plus le
moyen de répondre à la hausse de prix
donc le gars qui vend son produit 12
pièces qu'il manque 14 une inflation si
tout le monde n'achète quand même un 14
une petite tentation de le mettre à 15
peut-être donc plus les gens ont un
pouvoir d'achat plus l'inflation va être
facile à créer en même temps la personne
qui a vraiment besoin de 500 pièces il
faut quand même donner quelque chose
c'est nécessaire de faire ça mais les
critiques de cette mesure-là ça a été
que ils l'ont donné à tout le monde
pratiquement ils l'ont donné à tous ceux
qui font moins de 5000 dollars par année
puis ça c'est 94% des contribuables
québécois donc on peut dire que presque
tout le monde a reçu 500 pièces puis il
y en a là-dedans qui ont juste dit merci
puisqu'il y en a pas vraiment besoin
donc il y aurait peut-être pu en donner
plus à ceux qui font 23000 par année
puis laissez faire ceux qui font 19500
qui en avait peut-être moins besoin donc
c'est ça ça a été la critique principale
le gouvernement dit que tout le monde
était touché par l'inflation oui mais ça
fait pas mal également tout le monde
c'est plus progressistes on aurait
préféré que ce soit au ménage à faible
revenu plus tôt puis au niveau fédéral
mettons ici le fédéral se situe dans des
plutôt
à justement laisser pas trop de apporter
de l'aide ou dans le fédéral était
extrêmement généreux en fait le Canada
était un des pays en pourcentage du PIB
un pourcentage de la tête note économie
c'est un des pays les plus généreux
pendant la pandémie le déficit a été
historique c'est un déficit de guerre
mondiale je voulais plutôt dire dans les
dernières semaines moi le depuis le il y
a beaucoup de programmes qui sont qui
sont suspendus ou arrêtés parce que le
pire de la pandémie est passé on peut
dire que l'économie est reparti en
général
besoin de masque et tout il y a plus de
secteurs qui sont fermés à cause de la
pandémie donc mais le gouvernement dit
toujours qu'il va venir en aide à ceux
qui en ont besoin il y a des prestations
les gouvernements en fait les deux
paliers il y a des prestations pour
personnes âgées qui ont un peu augmenté
le 500 dollars aussi puis il va
peut-être en avoir un autre bientôt donc
les deux gouvernements les deux paliers
sont très très conscients qu'il y a des
gens qui en ont besoin et puis c'est le
rôle de gouvernement d'intervenir puis
même potentiellement de s'endetter quand
ça vaut pas bien
remboursé c'est difficile de quand ça va
mieux c'est ça l'économie publique
moi la première vie économiste je pense
que ça va coûter très cher à rembourser
parce qu'il va falloir rembourser sur un
jour donc à terme il va soit y avoir des
hausses d'impôts ou des coupures de
services tu peux pas arriver autrement
un budget équilibré mais il y avait pas
le choix pendant la pandémie le risque
était beaucoup plus grand de pas en
faire assez que d'en faire trop c'est en
faire trop ça crée de l'inflation puis
ça crée des dettes mais pas en faire
assez quand tu dis que presque totalité
de ta population travaille plus et chez
elle tu peux pas laisser ça même d'en
faire passer c'était plus un risque d'en
faire trop donc c'est dur programmer
quelques gouvernements que ce soit dans
le monde d'avoir trop dépensé d'argent
pendant la pandémie parce que c'était
juste jamais vu parce que dans faire pas
assez c'est là il y a des commerces qui
ont sont morts là tu sais carrément la
pandémie mais d'en faire moi toutes les
commerces à Montréal aurait fermé parce
que les loyers sont tellement étaient
tellement énormes c'est toutes les je
pense juste à au resto qui avait un peu
d'aide pour payer leur loyer puis
continuer à rouler mais ça reste à la
fin de ces commerces là ben de ceux-là
puis les gens qui étaient chez eux parce
que leur commettre même si c'est pas
restauration ou un hôtellerie ou en
culture les commerces fermés les gens
qui étaient chez eux s'il y avait pas eu
la PCI ouais comment y payer l'épicerie
ces gens-là il y avait un besoin c'était
une nécessité de faire ce que les
gouvernements ont fait il y en a qui
disent qu'il y a peut-être trop de
milliers de milliards mais c'est facile
à dire après tout le temps puis dans un
an on va se dire oh la banque centrale
aurait peut-être dû augmenter plus ou
moins les taux d'intéressent tout le
temps faciles après mais moi je voudrais
pas être d'un soulier de du patron de la
Banque du Canada ou de fédéral parce que
c'est c'est vraiment un équilibre
extrêmement dur de faire atterrir une
économie qui surchauffe sans créer une
récession c'est difficile de faire ça et
puis si tu es bien parti ben il y a
beaucoup qui disent qui sont en retard
que l'inflation
aurait jamais dû se rendre là puis en
fait ça me vantait où je travaille nous
on voyait l'inflation venir depuis
longtemps
des économistes disaient que ce serait
pas si ils sont trompés cette majorité
là parce que
je peux pas injecter des milliers de
milliards sans savoir qui va l'inflation
un petit peu plus loin d'économie de
base donc c'était étonnant de voir à
quel point plusieurs économistes étaient
dans le délit sur l'inflation c'est un
peu ça ma question tantôt quand je
disais que il y a une partie de
spéculation parce que si c'était une
équation clair sans équivoque que tout
le monde à l'équation tout le monde a
Pythagore ton incapable de prendre
Pythagore mais ça c'était toujours la
bonne décision
qui est politique dans tout ça ben parce
que on pourrait jamais le prouver mais
moi j'ai un peu l'impression qu'il y
avait quand même des commandes
politiques de augmenter les taux
d'intérêt trop vite parce que c'est pas
très populaire à l'approche d'une
élection que ce soit aux États-Unis ici
ou n'importe où là je parle pas du
Québec parce que le Québec a pas de
banque centrale on parle de politique en
général en
Occident dans les pays qui nous
ressemblent un peu là c'est pas très
populaire pour un gouvernement qui
servent à l'élection que l'économie
aille moins bien parce que tout
l'intérêt monde puis que ça ralentit
l'économie
donc je pense que la presse s'il y en
avait une la pression politique était de
garder les taux le plus bas possible le
plus longtemps possible c'est ce qu'on
voit en Europe en Europe l'inflation est
très forte puis madame Lagarde qui est
président de la Banque centrale
européenne pas encore vraiment commencé
à augmenter les taux là bas je suis
Bodart un peu de politique parce que les
chiffres montrent qu'il faudrait
vraiment y voir au plus vite parce que
l'inflation en Allemagne est à 10 %, il
n'a pas de bon sens
j'ai lu le terme
stack flash
ont appris cette année qui lorsqu'on a
une forte
il est parti sur Twitter avec
stackflation
suivi
donc ça c'est bien compris c'est quand
qu'on a une forte inflation commence
maintenant mais
de manière générale quand on a une
inflation ça veut dire que l'économie
surchauffe accélère
c'est quand en plus d'avoir l'inflation
l'économie va pas bien ça c'est le pire
c'est le pire des scénarios ben il y a
beaucoup d'économies qui ont peur
concernant vers ça mais là la croissance
est encore
est faible mais encore là donc
l'objectif des banques centrales ce
serait de tuer l'inflation puis de
garder une croissance peut-être de 0 ou
faible mais pas négative parce qu'une
récession techniquement c'est deux
trimestres de suite que l'économie
recule
c'est quand de six mois donc deux
trimestres consécutifs ou l'économie de
PIB ralenti rétrécie aux États-Unis le
premier trimestre ça reculer
donc c'est le deuxième trimestre
officiellement pour le savoir dans
quelques mois parce que les chiffres
arrivent après donc les États-Unis sont
peut-être déjà récession technique ça
paraît pas tellement parce que taux de
chômage est un boy historique puis il y
a une pénurie de main d'oeuvre les gens
peuvent changer d'emploi facilement
parce que il y a plus de demandes de
travailleurs que que demande de poste
donc c'est aussi c'est un autre aspect
de la demande la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre en général un travailleur est
content de se trouver une job à ce
moment les compagnies sont contents de
trouver du personnel puis on le voit
partout là je pense dans quel coin vous
venez mais on va donner quoi
c'est ça qui est beaucoup de restaurants
puis de même dans d'autres secteurs qui
sont fermés par manque de personnel ou
qui ont des heures beaucoup plus
réduites
il y en a beaucoup qui ont pris des
retraites anticipées puis il y en a
d'autres qui veulent plus accepter une
job qui n'aimait pas la a fait se
remettre en question bien des gens sur
cette quoi le bonheur aussi donc oui les
en ce moment c'est très difficile j'ai
des clients
qui ont des gens en entrevue qui sont
embauchés pour le lundi qui suit puis
ils viennent même pas sans appeler
tellement
les attitudes ont changé aussi moi j'ai
52 ans je sais pas si vieux mais quand
je suis sorti de l'université j'étais
content d'avoir une job puis je te
laisse
entrevue
mais à ce moment on dirait que
je parle pas des jeunes les travailleurs
en ce moment ont comme l'impression que
c'est plus nécessaire d'être respectueux
que les autres qu'au moins qu'avant
c'est pas tout le monde qui est comme ça
mais des gens qui se présentent mais pas
ou qui se présentent un avant midi rendu
Hollande chez Régis qui aime pas ça puis
s'en vont sans le dire puis ils
reviennent plus on voyait pas ça avant
là c'est rendu un petit peu un petit peu
loin c'est un peu ça va
encore une fois je reviens on a répondu
partiellement mais je reviens en
question le monde est où parce que je
comprends que ça t'a donné deux bonnes
directions le monde est où mais est-ce
que c'est ça représente tout le monde
qui manque le tu les représentants
de changer d'emploi parce que mais pas
ce qu'il faisait travail encore sur le
marché mais il y a pas la tendance de
long terme aussi quand je disais que la
pandémie accélérée des tendances il y a
peut-être celle-là que les travailleurs
qui sont tenus s'en vont plus rien mais
il y avait une tendance de long terme
sous-jacente c'était la démographie
d'accélérer l'immigration et la
formation et tout ça parce que ça va
être nécessaire la solution à ça c'est
l'innovation si chaque travailleur
devient beaucoup plus performant parce
que il y a des technologies auto qui
l'aident à faire trois fois ce qui
faisait avant mais là la pénurie de
mainde va être un petit peu réglé mais
il faut vraiment investir en innovation
puis en robotique et tout ça et les
robots volent pas les jobs des
travailleurs ils aident à mieux faire
leur job il y a un préjugé là-dessus que
la robotisation ça vole des jobs non ça
aide juste à mieux faire ta job puis
c'est règle en partie la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre parce que un travailleur en
vaut 2 ou 3 c'est la tête
[Rires]
pour venir à la question suivante
le vieillissement de la population
le plus la plus grande démographie
mettons les baby-boomers qui sont qui
représentent le plus haut pourcentage de
la population
les autres tranquillement le marché de
l'emploi c'est déjà fait pour certains
pour son travail de quitter sont en
train de quitter ce qui pourrait
expliquer en partie ce qu'on voit
maintenant mais toutes ces gens-là qui
vont dans 20 ans quitter pas juste le
domaine des emplois mais quitter cette
pleine d'exister cette pleine
d'existence
ce royaume dans lequel on vit
ce qu'on entrevoit une problématique ça
va arriver parce que si mettons là pour
combler le besoin de toutes ces gens-là
faut booster le système de santé parce
qu'il va avoir on va avoir besoin de
plein de d'infirmières à la maison de
soins à domicile de maison des années
peu importe le système qu'on réussit à
s'entendre pour trouver
pour profiter de ce système qui était
mis en place c'est un danger qu'on peut
voir dans 20 ans avec le vieillissement
de la population moi je me pose tout le
temps cette question graduellement parce
que c'est une génération qui court
plusieurs années donc puis je pense que
les leçons j'espère que les leçons qu'on
a là qu'on s'est pas préparé assez vite
pour l'explosion de ces gens-là qu'on va
quand même prévoir les choses pour quand
ça va peut-être s'amuser mais petit la
démographie reste comme elle y aura
toujours trop de retraités par
travailleur donc peut-être pour toujours
mais si ça se règle pas quoi si ça se
règle pas mathématiquement ça mène à
zéro humain sa taille
quoi qu'il y a des pays où c'est
l'Afrique côté démographique c'est
l'Afrique qui va générer le plus de
nouvelles personnes dans les prochaines
années d'ailleurs c'est bon pour le
Québec puis le Français sont Riverdale
on reviendra ça
mais
pour l'instant l'urgence c'est de
s'assurer que les personnes âgées qui
sont de plus en plus nombreuses puis les
petits bobos qui apparaissent de plus en
plus en proportion il faut y répondre
puis la pandémie a montré que le système
de santé était peut-être pas prêt à
gérer toutes les crises puis il était
extrêmement fragilisé puis recruter du
monde dans un système qui va pas bien
qui va déjà pas bien créer des burn out
parce que justement
pour nous autres
épuisez-vous donc
certains y ont mis certaines mesures en
place de prime tout ça m'intégrer quand
il y a du temps supplémentaire
obligatoire des affaires comme ça c'est
pas des comptes c'est des conditions qui
étaient peut-être nécessaires à certains
moments mais qui attire pas tellement la
main d'oeuvre en général donc il faut
s'ajuster à ça je pense que c'est je
pense que c'est un chemin c'est
justement là puis juste une sous
question de ma voiture
par rapport à ça justement puis
peut-être faire le pont avec le marché
de l'immobilier qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure si moi je pense à un quartier
comme le quartier j'étais parent c'est
Sylvie à Québec le truc est un quartier
pratiquement 90% de baby-boomers
soit en
CHSLD ou maison des années ou peu
importe il va te faire avoir un énorme
crush quand ces gens-là vont décider de
quitter leur domicile ben il y a une
chose qu'il faudrait faire c'est plus de
soin à domicile plutôt que des CHSLD ou
en guillemets au parc les gens il y a
plusieurs personnes âgées qui voudraient
rester dans leur maison le plus
longtemps
puis certains gouvernements dans le
passé qui voulaient faire ce virage là
puis donc gouvernement les remplacait
puis il était moins pressé là-dessus
mais moi je suis de l'école qu'il
faudrait augmenter les ressources dans
les soins à domicile pour les gens qui
veulent rester chez eux c'est réglerait
beaucoup de problèmes parce que ça
coûterait pas tellement plus cher en
bout de ligne que de faire des méga
CHSLD donc
ça c'est clair que les gens qui veulent
rester chez eux parce qu'ils veulent pas
s'en aller ailleurs que chez eux qui ont
vécu c'est eux qui ont construit leurs
affaires puis ils veulent rester là puis
il y en a beaucoup qui peuvent encore
manifester sont encore assez semi
autonome ou autonome pour rester chez
eux puis même quand ils deviennent un
peu plus fragile ou malade avec quel que
soit pour être très bien finir leur jour
chez eux puis à ce moment il y a une
trop grande proportion qui sont quand
même forcés d'aller en CHSLD pour raison
X ou Y moi j'ai miserais plus sur les
soins à domicile
j'avais deux questions que j'ai pas posé
une première c'est par rapport justement
à peine une main d'oeuvre c'est quoi la
solution c'est l'immigration c'en est
une temporaire peut-être parce que on
peut pas juste régler ça d'un coup en
faisant venir 3 millions de personnes
parce qu'il faut les une capacité de
d'accueil aussi moi j'ai toujours trouvé
que faire venir quelqu'un à l'étranger
qui fuit la précarité pour faire venir à
cette personne là précarité chez nous
c'est pas mieux là donc il faut il faut
regarder la capacité d'accueil ça ça m'a
toujours
méduser les partis politiques qui
s'estiment c'est tout 50 non c'est 45 -
60000 dans ses 22000 sans se demander
combien au point d'accueillir à l'époque
moi j'étais d'accord avec l'idée de
donner un mandat aux vérificateur
général ou je sais pas quelle
institution de calculer la capacité
d'accueil du Québec pour que ces gens-là
soient bien en arrivant surtout point de
vue économique culturels
combien on peut accueillir on ouvre les
gate puis on les accueille mais de dire
50000 parce que c'est payant dans ta
clientèle électorale puis dès 32000
parce que c'est plus payant d'un autre
région ça c'est pas de belles politiques
à mon avis il faut faire ça
intelligemment
l'immigration est une solution mais
encore une fois comme je disais tantôt
c'est l'innovation je pense la clé c'est
de faire en sorte que tous ceux qui
travaillent mieux ça passe par
l'éducation quand je parle de
l'innovation je parle d'éducation en
général
tous les pays ont deux outils pour
pour s'avancer il y a la nature qui est
donnée qui est là puis à l'éducation qui
nous permet de comment qui nous dit
comment on veut utiliser la nature les
ressources et tout ça puis il faut miser
sur l'éducation à tout point de vue puis
un peuple mieux éduqué travail mieux et
plus productif donne plus de revenus à
l'état parce que tu as des salaires plus
élevés quand tu es une formation plus
avancée donc il y a juste du positif
là-dedans c'est pour ça que c'était pour
la gratuité scolaire dans le temps que
je suis en politique parce que
quand on le regarde le débat très
rapidement les gens disent écoute bien
trop cher on peut pas enlever les frais
de scolarité les universités ont besoin
d'argent mais après quelques années de
gratuité scolaire à peu près tout le
monde en moyenne est allé un peu plus
loin dans son parcours parce qu'il y
avait aucune barrière financière ou
encore plus de gens vont plus loin dans
leur parcours de formation quelles
qu'elles soient pas dire des docteurs
pour tout le monde ça peut être un
métier très technique mais tu es allé
chercher une formation de plus parce que
c'était gratuit et ces gens-là ont tous
des salaires plus élevés parce qu'ils
sont mieux formés et les salaires plus
élevés les impôts sont plus élevés puis
les impôts additionnels qu'on retire de
tout ça valent plus que les frais de
scolarités qu'on a éliminés donc c'est
un choix économique positif pour les
finances publiques même des frais de
scolarité sauf que faut avoir la vision
de passer dans 5 ou 10 dizaines parce
qu'il faut que la roue commence à
tourner des impôts plus élevés alors que
ceux qui pensent au prochain budget à la
prochaine élection mais ça prend de la
vision en fait mais quand on a une
vision politique de long terme la
gratuité scolaire c'est une excellente
idée même sur le plan économique pas sur
le plan philosophique
on change tout le monde à chaque 4 ans
on change tout le monde tu as le droit à
4 ans peu importe il y a pas de partie
tu as le droit à 4 ans à chaque 4 ans on
change tout le monde puis tout le monde
tu sais que ça va être ça tout le monde
tu sais que dans 4 ans c'est fini il y a
des pays qui ont opté aux États-Unis tu
peux être président juste demandeurs
c'est tout il y a des gens qui
commencent à instaurer ça quatre ans ça
peut être court parfois quand un projet
immense par contre mais moi je suis en
faveur aussi de dire parce que ça enlève
la tentation d'être électoraliste
les présidents dans les pays qui font 5
6 7 8 mois de suite ça donnera rarement
quelque chose dans l'emballant à la fin
il s'installe un espèce de nonchalance
puis de
des comportements pas très désirables
mais un mandat de 4 ans c'est peut-être
un peu court à limite allongé peut-être
mais je serai aussi en accord que les
gens qui sont là savent qui sont là pour
eux à faire puis pas penser à leur
élection mais pensez à l'intérêt
collectif c'est ça pensez à mettre en
place des affaires qui vont se
développer dans le temps passer
l'intérêt collectif plutôt qu'à la
survie de ton parti à la réélection de
ta gagne ça c'est sûr que ce serait
positif mettez depuis tantôt souvent
justement la solution que tu proposes ça
serait juste de calculons-le arrivons à
la donner la plus objective possible
puis faisons ça puis on dirait que ça ça
devrait être
une certitude une évidence
Revolution ok mais c'était quand même
très politique
c'est quand tu dis on va d'abord
calculer c'est quoi l'intérêt collectif
les parties s'entendent pas sur c'est
quoi l'intérêt collectif et des parties
qui disent que l'intérêt collectif il va
être atteint si tout le monde est libre
de faire ce qu'il veut donc le moins de
gouvernement possible de réglementation
puis d'autres qui disent que le
gouvernement doit être assez gros et
fort pour intervenir dans le cas de la
pandémie le deuxième cas pas mal gagné
le sien peut être le gouvernement tout
le monde aurait été vraiment dans le
trouble mais en fait il y a une formule
simple que j'aime bien pour résumer la
droite et la gauche en politique
les gens de droite ils font l'hypothèse
qu'on est tous égaux au départ puis
débrouille-toi force-toi tonton
mais donc à droite ils font l'hypothèse
que tout le monde est égal au départ
puis la gauche fait le souhait que tout
le monde soit égal à l'arrivée donc on
met en place des
systèmes sociaux puis un filet social
puis des protections pour les plus
démunis
je pense qu'au Québec on est dans un
juste milieu de tout seul même quand le
gouvernement change au Québec c'est
personne qui veut détruire les filières
sociales puis enlever toutes les
programmes il y en a il y a des parties
plus de droite d'autres plus de gauche
ou de centres droites centres gauche
mais le Québec en général est un état
progressif un peu comme les pays
scandinaves même ce gouvernement un peu
plus de droite était élu il coupe pas le
filet social du jour au lendemain mais
puis moi je me suis plus centre gauche
moi je suis pas un État fort
qu'intervient quand c'est nécessaire
puis qui favorise quand même
l'innovation c'est pas une contradiction
tu peux être un gouvernement très fort
et très présent mais qui favorise
l'innovation du secteur privé puis ça se
voit puis les meilleures années
économiques qu'on connaît c'est quand
les deux sont les deux sont réunis
du braquage justement de favorite de
favoriser l'innovation puis facteur tu
es pas pour un retour mettons
pour décroissance par exemple pour
la décroissance je pense que nécessaire
mais le marketing est vraiment mauvais
le marketing autour de la décroissance
entre le fait d'innover peut avoir des
nouvelles technologies encore plus utile
et préserver l'environnement au
contraire même ça peut être très très
aligné mais le fait qu'il faut utiliser
moins de ressources ou réutiliser les
ressources qu'on veut créer autre chose
l'économie circulaire et tout ça donc
les déchets d'une industrie sont les
intrants de l'autre industrie plutôt que
d'aller extraire de nouvelles ressources
dans des existent dans un dépotoir donc
la décroissance à mon sens ça devrait
être enseigner dans dans l'angle qu'on
peut faire autant avec pas plus de
ressources on peut on peut même faire
plus avec les mêmes ressources ou même
son innove plus avec moins de ressources
mais quand on entend parler de
décroissance si jamais est-ce que ça
t'intéresse la décroissance économique
elle dans sa tête ça sonne on va tout
être plus pauvre donc non ça m'intéresse
pas donc je trouve qu'on va tous rouler
en vélo il y a plus personne qui a une
voiture même plus de vélo ça prend du
métal mais bref mais la décroissance je
trouve que c'est un c'est presque une
nécessité à terme parce que les
ressources la planète sont finies c'est
mathématiques donc on peut pas toujours
avoir un modèle ou le PIB il faut
absolument qu'il soit 3 % plus élevé
chaque année tu peux pas parce que les
ressources sont pas augmenter de 3 %.
donc un mur à ça mais je changerai les
mots parce que les mots sont importants
quand tu veux convaincre une population
de quelque chose là je pense que le mot
décroissance c'est pas très habile ça
devrait être plus d'efficacité je veux
pas penser à quel mot ça devrait être
mais il faudrait l'enseigner
différemment parce que c'est dur de se
faire des adeptes quand le message a
l'air de demander à quelqu'un d'être
moins bien donc mais c'est nécessaire de
mieux faire les choses l'économie
circulaire est une des solutions
l'économie sociale en état aussi
l'entrepreneuriat collectif aussi au
Québec on a la chance d'être avancé
là-dedans qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
entrepreneuriat collectif mais les
coupes et les Obs qui sont des business
parce qu'il y en a des OBNL c'est pas
tout dans le secteur communautaire c'est
pas tout c'est plutôt des des organismes
financiers par l'État par exemple pour
une mission et des eaux beneL qui sont
des commerces par exemple les shopungus
au coeur de Montréal
c'est un OBNL immobilier qui joue en
centaines de millions mais c'est un OBNL
quand ils ont des profits ils peuvent
juste les réinvestir dans un autre
projet ça vaut pas dans les poches de
qui que ce soit de privé puis quoi c'est
pareil il y a pas d'actionnaires dans
une coopérative c'est pour un service à
une communauté ça peut être la planète
la communauté ça peut être un village ça
peut être un rang mais bref
l'entrepreneuriat collectif L'Avantage
que ça a c'est que dans sa façon même de
fonctionner ça respecte les trois
principes de SG environnement
acceptabilité sociale et bonne
gouvernance c'est dans la mécanique de
l'entreprise que c'est déjà respecté à
la base ou plus respecter évidemment tu
peux toujours trouver des exceptions
négatives à quoi que ce soit mais
l'avantage de l'entrepreneur collectif
c'est que dans la dans l'ADN de ces
entreprises là il y a un meilleur
partage la richesse parce que
protectionnaire et un meilleur respect
de l'environnement parce que souvent les
projets sont
issus de la localité ou le projet a lieu
donc personne ne veut pas lui son
environnement où il vit
c'est contrairement à certaines
multinationales et qui peuvent aller
puiser et ensuite ils voient plus le
site ça les dérangement plus accuse pas
toutes les multinationales mais donc la
tendance est plus forte sur une
multinationale que sur une entreprise
locale de se [ __ ] un peu de ce que tu
vois directement ce que tu fais
exactement puis sur le plan gouvernance
c'est un peu plus démocratique une
coopérative aussi parce que c'est une
personne un vote et non une action un
vote dans le secteur privé qui est
nécessaire à l'économie aussi dans le
secteur privé un actionnaire qui est 51%
des actions de la compagnie des autres
peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent ils
décident dans une coopérative même si un
millionnaire est dans le CA ou aux
membres de coopérative au même titre que
quelqu'un de 19 ans qui est encore aux
études ils vont avoir un vote chacun
donc une gouvernance un peu plus
démocratique qui a certains tournants
importants dans une entreprise dans
l'histoire de l'entreprise peuvent venir
à des décisions bien différentes donc je
pense que c'est pas évidemment c'est pas
une panacée mais c'est un des outils
c'est une des solutions aux modèles qui
fonctionnent plus le modèle actuel il
fonctionne pas de tout le temps vouloir
la croissance infinie dans toute
à l'entreprise il faut dominer le monde
puis exporter dans 28 pays le lendemain
ça marche juste pas avec les ressources
de la planète puis la capacité de la
planète de soutenir ce modèle là ça
prendrait 5 planètes pour soutenir ces
modèles là ça a pas de sens inspire je
me suis impuissé c'est quoi la date là
mais il y a une date officielle au début
de l'année où on a utilisé les
ressources d'une année de la planète
mais c'était genre en janvier le
deuxième de janvier ça c'était pour les
PDG de salaire des PDG après quelques
jours au début de l'année ils ont gagné
l'équivalent de leur travailleur moyenne
pour la vie de la planète c'est un petit
peu plus mais c'est plus rapide c'est
inquiétant à quel point c'est rapide et
donc l'entrepreneuriat collectif ça aide
à changer ce modèle là il faut que ça en
face partie au même titre que le secteur
privé puis que les gouvernements il y a
trois piliers le collectif le privé plus
gouvernement et le Québec on a la chance
l'immense chance de délirer mondiaux
là-dedans en entrepreneur collectif on
est une référence dans le monde il y a
le chantier d'économie sociale où j'ai
déjà été déjà j'ai eu la chance de
passer par là c'est une référence
mondiale il y a des délégations d'autres
pays qui viennent voir au chantier comme
un Québec a fait ça pour essayer de le
faire chez eux parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que dans les crises économiques
plus il y a de coopératives mieux ça va
parce que quoi ça fait pas faillite
autant qu'une compagnie privée les gens
ça à l'écoute puis font que la Coop
survie alors qu'un privé une tentation
quand il fait 7 % de rendement ici puis
qui se rend compte peut-être qu'en
Malaisie il pourrait faire du 8 et demi
parce que cela sont plus bas les
actionnaires vont voter pour faire ça
parce que ils veulent augmenter le
rendement d'entreprise une coopérative
fera pas ça un OBNL non plus se
délocalise jamais pour payer moins de
salaire donc il y a une espèce sociale
puis là je suis en train d'accuser les
privés des sauvages là mais disons qu'il
y a pas cette tentation là dans le
collecte dans les coopératives les eaux
benelles ou les entreprises collectives
et le Québec comme je disais c'est 10
12% de notre économie qui vient de
secteur là c'est pas mal un sommet
mondial puis au Québec le chiffre
d'affaires des coopératives au Québec
c'est 50 milliards par année c'est
immense c'est les gens soupçonnent pas
ça c'est plus gros que la construction
c'est immense au Québec puis en 2008 on
a mieux traversé la crise que à peu près
partout ailleurs dans le monde en partie
grâce grâce à ça à ce grand nombre de
coup à plats qui faisait pas faillite
parce que toute faillite officielle
c'est des chiffres gouvernementaux
officielle des ou les taux de succès je
voudrais dire le taux de survie sur 10
ans de quoi par rapport au privé c'est
le double
il y a deux entreprises privées sur 10
seulement qui survivent dix ans il y a
beaucoup de roulements là-dedans sont
très résilientes puis c'est bon en plus
pour des localités mais c'est bon pour
une communauté urbaine de Montréal au
Québec mais dans des localités un peu
plus éloignées en région ou un peu plus
rural c'est bon que ces emplois là ces
entreprises-là soient réelles soient
pérennes et brésiliennes parce que ça ça
fait moins de dévitalisation donc il y a
plein d'aspects positifs à ça qu'on
sous-estime au Québec en fait la force
du collectif on est chanceux est-ce que
la
tentation à l'innovation est aussi fort
dans collectif mettons s'il y a pas de
le potentiel de s'enrichir autant
pousser à vouloir trouver des solutions
pour rentrer plus efficace
oui puis surtout sous forme d'innovation
sociale parce l'innovation c'est pas
juste des technologies c'est pas juste
du numérique puis de l'informatique ça
peut être innovation sociale aussi les
CPE sont issus de ça c'est une
innovation sociale incroyable qui a
amené des milliers de femmes plus sur le
marché du travail parce qu'elle pouvait
enfin travailler le jour donc c'est ça
c'est économiquement c'est G1 puis c'est
une innovation sociale qui peut
numériques du tout les aides à domicile
dont on parlait tantôt toutes les
réseaux des aides à domicile qui est
souvent en collectif au bien-être ça a
permis à bien des gens de rester chez
eux aussi donc l'innovation sociale dans
le pays B si on pouvait la mesurer aussi
précisément que qu'un bilan comptable on
verrait que économiquement c'est aussi
important que l'innovation technologique
dans bien des secteurs et le collectif
est très fort en innovation sociale
c'est sûr que si la compagnie Apple
avait été un OBNL l'iPhone serait
peut-être moins développé qu'il est là
parce qu'il y avait une poursuite une
poursuite du succès et du rendement puis
de puis des ventes et tout c'est devenu
plus grosse compagnie au monde en étant
privé je pense pas qu'en OBNL appelle ça
aurait pu arriver appelle serait aussi
grosses mais il y a pour ça que ça prend
une certaine balance c'est ça mais je
parlais des trois secteurs et des trois
piliers et un prof de Montréal qui
s'appelle Henry mindsburg un gourou du
management connu mondialement et
tamaguil il y a une grande carrière puis
lui il décrit la satiété comme ayant
trois piliers le gouvernement que tout
le monde connaît le privé que tout le
monde connaît aussi et le collectif qui
est ni contrôlé par le gouvernement ni
par le privé donc il y a trois pattes
puis se collectif là c'est ça c'est
l'économie sociale c'est les syndicats
les associations quelconque
et les sociétés les plus évoluées ou les
plus développées ou les plus prospères
ou les plus heureuses sont celles dont
les trois piliers sont les plus forts et
les plus équilibrés puis le Québec en
fait partie ou une petite tpiste
scandinaves certaines régions de
l'Italie aussi donc ces trois piliers
l'image qu'utilisent un tabouret qui a
trois pattes si tu enlèves une des trois
pattes n'importe laquelle collectif mais
si tu enlèves une des trois pattes ont
toujours trop pencher à gauche ou à
droite puis utilise l'exemple de
l'Europe et quelques décennies où le
piliers gouvernemental était beaucoup
trop fort l'univers soviétique toute
personne était heureux les États-Unis
les pays privés et beaucoup trop fort
quand tu dis que la première cause de
faillite aux États-Unis c'est les soins
de santé parce qu'il y a pas de pilule
gouvernementale assez fort c'est triste
un peu dans le pays plus riche au monde
donc les piliers est trop fort au privé
aux États-Unis il était trop fort au
gouvernement en Europe de l'Est donc il
faut que les trois piliers soient
équilibrés
collectif trop fort non ça c'est jamais
arrivé encore parce qu'il est encore en
développement dans bien des régions
c'est une question que j'ai déjà eu ça
maintenant
mais oui qui est collectif ait pris trop
de place puis on est pas encore arrivé
là parce que bien qu'au Québec il soit
très très fort il est loin d'être trop
dominant
parce que il y a un fondement très
démocratique au pays collectif donc si
les gens qui verraient m'ont donné qu'il
y en a assez parce que c'est eux qui
choisiraient d'aller plus loin non et on
se fait de quoi j'accroche quelque chose
c'est eux qui déciderait d'aller plus
loin ou non alors que dans le pilier
privé ou puis le gouvernemental les abus
sont plus faciles parce que ils ont
quand même l'applique gouvernemental
mais peut-être pas ici mais dans
certaines régions du monde c'est facile
ça parait de pouvoir peut-être garder
par des façons moins que positif
c'est un billet privé si le gouvernement
est trop faible il y a trop de
déréglementations c'est le privé
lui-même qui décide de ses règles puis
là ça tourne toujours mal surtout dans
ce secteur bancaire secteur bancaire aux
États-Unis il y a eu des cycles de
déréglementation de relementation puis
chaque fois qu'on est à la fin d'un
cycle de déréglementation il y a quelque
chose qui pète quelque part en 2008
c'était les
subprimes qu'on appelle il prêtait des
des sommes incroyables pour acheter des
maisons à des gens qui avaient pas les
moyens du tout rembourser ça si le prix
de la maison baissait le moindrement
puis quand c'est éclaté ça va être la
crise mondiale qu'on a connu en 2008
donc il faut il y a pas un secteur qui
est plus important que l'autre il faut
que les trois soient très équilibré
ceci dit encore le secteur
gouvernemental qui devrait avoir
le dernier mot parce que c'est le seul
auquel toute la population participe
prennent aux élections entre autres donc
les acteurs pour moi le secteur
gouvernemental devrait encore être celui
qui décide des règles dans le secteur
privé dans le secteur collectif
puis par rapport
peut-être en toi tu parlais de récession
possible c'est plus aux États-Unis qu'on
avait déjà remarqué un premier trimestre
qui était négatif qu'est-ce qu'un indice
du Québec est-ce qu'on a ce que on est
encore dans le positif est-ce que puis
même le ministre des Finances ici croit
qu'on va pouvoir peut-être passer tout
ça sans récession j'ai lu qui dit qu'il
avait 35% de chance
moi je suis plus d'avis que c'est plus
que 33% parce que aux États-Unis ils
sont déjà dans un ralentissement puis le
Québec le Canada en fait si les
États-Unis vont mal on a les contrecoups
de ça parce que notre principal marché
est de loin on est tellement intégré on
est plus intégré que les États-Unis que
les pays de l'Union européenne entre eux
c'est vraiment comme un grand marché
l'Amérique du Nord et donc si les
États-Unis sont à récession ce serait
très difficile pour le Québec de pas
tomber en peut-être en légère et session
mais ne pas en connaître une parce que
quand on principal client arrête
d'acheter c'est c'est sûr de changer
tout de suite ta structure de clients
rapidement puis de toute façon si les
États-Unis sont arrêtés
une bonne partie de l'économie mondiale
aussi c'est un trop grand importateur de
plein de choses puis de consommateurs de
plein de choses donc si eux ralentissent
à peu près tous les fournisseurs partout
vont ralentir aussi donc moi je suis pas
pessimiste sur l'économie du Québec là
on voit très bien s'en sortir comme on
l'a toujours fait mais ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup qui est pas un ralentissement
ça c'est sûr qu'il va en avoir un puis
ça m'étonnerait un peu qu'il y a pas de
récession relativement c'est fort pour
que deux trimestres de suite ce soit
légèrement négatif je serais pas surpris
de ça c'est pas une certitude mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour le
citoyen
ça va rééquilibrer certaines choses
entre autres le marché immobilier il y a
pas de bon sens en ce moment ça va
peut-être ramener une normalité dans le
marché immobilier puis augmenter à
nouveau l'accessibilité la première
propriété pour bien des gens ça va
peut-être réglé en partie la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre aussi parce que si
l'économie ralentit un peu ça va se
restabiliser donc c'est les récession
c'est un peu comme une fièvre des fois
le corps a besoin d'une fièvre pour
évacuer quelque chose on l'aime pas la
fièvre on voudrait s'en passer mais des
fois c'est bon
donc la récession dans un cycle
économique c'est presque une nécessité
ceci dit ce serait pas nécessaire si les
cycles économiques étaient mieux rigides
par moins d'excès quand l'argent était
gratuit là on s'est lancé dans plein
d'excès ont été la population
les mêmes stats ça vous dit quelque
chose il y avait des réseaux sociaux
comme Reddit ou une gang se disait on
achète ce stock là on le fan pour rire
ça faisait monter le prix instable c'est
l'archétype du même stock et ça ça fait
en sorte que il y a plein de je pense
c'est boursicateurs en français les
détrueux des gens qui connaissent pas
qui savent même pas ce que la compagnie
produit ça même pas si la compagnie va
être rentable ou non dans les prochaines
années mais il investissent dedans parce
que ça monte et ça c'est très dangereux
cette semaine à des excès fou et
d'ailleurs GameStop replanté aussi vite
que tu as monté les gens qui ont acheté
au sommet presque tout perdu un peu
comme
de sa valeur assez vite donc
les abus qu'on a eu les abus du cycle
économique actuel puis du modèle actuel
mène du beau mène Bast qu'on appelle en
anglais donc ça croit trop vite puis
pendant un certain temps puis après ça
une récession pour calmer tout ça
le Saint Graal de l'économie ce serait
d'avoir une économie qui ronronne à deux
trois à deux pour cent par année ou
quelque chose comme ça puis même encore
les adeptes de la décroissance voudrait
l'économie arrête de croire parce que je
peux pas croire tout le temps que les
ressources finies mais bref dans le
contexte de ce qu'on discute si un
gouvernement trouvait la façon de faire
en sorte que la croissance soit stable
base tout le temps tout le temps ce
serait préférable à des croissances de
5% puis des récessions après faudrait
que ce soit moins axé sur la spéculation
a moins gros impact la spéculation est
une immense joueur dans ce qu'on vient
de discuter puis entre autres mais les
actions mais l'immobilier aussi le
Bitcoin en fait dans les dernières
années puis dans toutes les bulles ça
devient
les gens ont l'impression que c'est trop
facile de s'enrichir vite qui saute dans
le bateau c'est la fameuse peur de
manquer le bateau
dernières années en finance les gens
disent ça monte il faut que j'aille puis
ça se faisait monter encore puis l'autre
qui dit récemment encore parce que plus
tu achètes plus ça monte mais un moment
donné
qui va et lui va mal descendre ça fait
deux minutes parce que il y en a qui ont
acheté sur des marges il y en a qui
après étaient pour rentrer dans ce
marché là qui montait mais quand
t'emprunt puis que ça se met à descendre
ce qu'on appelle un appel de marge il te
demande de rembourser tout de suite mais
t'as pas nécessairement l'argent
peut-être
ceux qui ceux qui par exemple ont acheté
à crédit des actions à leur sommet puis
quasiment à descendre tu avais moins
cher pour rembourser ta dette pour le
tarif pas donc c'est ça le problème du
système financier actuel c'est qu'il y a
eu trop d'abus il y a eu une euphorie en
fait comme dans toutes les bulles puis à
travers l'histoire il y en a eu des
bulles financières économiques qui vont
en avoir d'autres pas la dernière il y
en a eu des bulles incroyables un
certain moment au Japon il y avait une
belle immobilière à la fin du 20e siècle
1990 90 un certain moment les jardins du
palais à Tokyo pas impérial valait plus
que l'entièreté du Canada en foncier ça
veut pas de sens qui est d'ailleurs ça
c'est éclaté et à ce jour depuis 1990 la
Bourse de Tokyo a toujours pas récupéré
son niveau là on est 30 ans plus tard
sont encore en bas de ce qui était à
l'époque c'était toute une bulle puis
d'autres bulles la bulle des tulipes je
sais pas si vous dit quelque chose au
Pays-Bas à l'époque il s'est mis à avoir
une spéculation sur les bulbes de
tulipes la fleur un bulbe valait plus
qu'une maison à l'époque oui il y avait
une folie absurde qui évidemment éclatée
tout le monde veut embarquer puis tout
le monde veut pas manquer le train donc
c'est ça qui fait l'effet de masse et
moi ça me fait dire que la finance on
devrait quand même faire confiance aux
professionnels donc soit les gens
connaissent ça très bien sont faits
leurs affaires ou remettez un
professionnel comme on ferait avec la
médecine ou n'importe quel autre service
mais les gens on dirait qu'ils les gens
se rendent pas compte
que c'est important d'avoir une retraite
où tu vas regarder un but de vie assez
similaire et qu'il faut épargner et
qu'il faut investir et c'est pris trop à
la légère je pense par bien des gens il
faut pas non plus commencer à stresser à
22 ans pour sa retraite c'est pas ça je
dis mais les gens qui pensent que c'est
un jeu puis moi l'expression jouer à la
Bourse je trouve pas c'est un jeu cette
attention qui est là-dedans donc il
faudrait qu'on revienne une économie
plus j'aurais plus sage où on analyse
les choses avant d'investir ce que les
professionnels font donc ce que je
voulais dire tantôt dans les stocks qui
étaient sur certains réseaux sociaux que
les gens embarquent dedans pour le fun
ils savaient même pas ce que
l'accompagner produisait vendait ou
c'est pronostics
il y avait aussi le désir de s'enrichir
vite parce qu'il voyait monter ça puis
se disait ça va être plus cher demain
puis au eu raison longtemps ça a duré
longtemps cette espèce de hausse là mais
un moment donné ça arrête tu en trouves
pas un plus gros poisson à un moment
donné pour acheter plus cher que toi tu
as acheté un autre qui était plus gros
poisson que celui à qui l'a acheté
il faut revenir à l'analyse fondamentale
qu'on achète une action une obligation
n'importe quoi il faut savoir dans quoi
on met notre argent puis ça irait pas
mal mieux comme ça ça enlèverait
beaucoup de spéculations beaucoup deux
forêt puis d'effet de masse la
psychologie des marchés est assez est
assez simple les effets sont très
traitements les exemples de gens qui
sont devenus millionnaires avec les
Bitcoin sont tellement
glamorisés on voudrait tellement ça
c'est sûr
c'est sûr qu'on appelle les chanceux
parce que c'est vrai que dans toutes les
bulles il y a des richesses incroyables
qui sont créés mais c'est ceux qui
embarquent à la fin
qui bénéficient pas
une pièce quelqu'un qui l'a perdu
ailleurs donc puis c'est encore plus
vrai dans les crypto puis moi les crypto
monnaie c'est pas ton truc je sais que
des gens qui sont arrivés avec ça puis
je suis bien content pour eux mais c'est
basé sur rien le blockchain j'y crois la
technologie en dessous c'est une
technologie valable qui va être
appliquée plein de choses j'en suis sûr
mais la crypto monnaie elle-même ça
devrait même pas s'appeler de monnaie
parce que quand la monnaie fluctue plus
que les choses que tu veux acheter avec
la monnaie c'est pas une monnaie mais
pourquoi que la crypto monnaie est moins
Montréal c'est moins de monnaie que le
dollars
tu sais qu'un gouvernement puis une
Banque du Canada qui te dit tapisasse à
une pièce une confiance les crypto
monnaie c'est basé sur rien d'autre que
l'espérance que quelqu'un l'achète plus
cher il y a pas de
fiduciaire dans une crypto-monnaie c'est
basé sur la confiance que quelqu'un va
te le racheter plus cher mais j'ai un
ami libanais que tout perdu parce que il
y a une hyper inflation puis ils sont
l'argent vaut plus rien
qu'est-ce qui fait que ça pourrait
arriver
où l'inflation est hors de contrôle
c'est une dévaluation ton pouvoir
d'achat mais si imagine si la monnaie
officielle de ce pays-là était la crypto
monnaie qui perd 70% de sa valeur en
plus c'est il y a des pays les Salvador
en fait le président décrété lui qui
aimait les Bitcoin qui a cours légal
là-bas mais je suggérais aucun pays de
mettre ses réserves en crypto monnaie
qui peut fluctuer de 50% dans une
semaine ça n'a aucun sens c'est quand
même de toute façon on va avoir une
monnaie globale qui va être qui va être
numérique crypto monnaie j'en suis à peu
près convaincu mais va être contrôlé par
les banques centrales qui ont une valeur
fiduciaire dans une économie qui
fonctionne un système de droit de
propriété puis de confiance et tu sais
que si tu crées d'entreprise au Québec
puis que tu es un brevet est à toi puis
à protéger mais la monnaie c'est un peu
ça les gens savent que le dollar
canadien il vaut 1 dollar il peut avoir
de l'inflation dessus mais c'est une
monnaie qui solide comme le dollar
américain l'euro etc les crypto monnaie
quelle qu'elle soit il y a pas de la
Bitcoin il y a rien qui soutient sa
valeur absolument rien c'est juste de
l'espoir que quelqu'un va l'acheter plus
cher ça a marché longtemps puis il y en
a qui sont enrichis comme on disait il y
a eu des milliardaires de créer
là-dedans il y a des milliardaires de
défaits aussi mais ceux qui ont eu la
chance de sortir au sommeil ils ont fait
un coup d'argent incroyable mais c'est
pas ça une économie solide tu peux pas
passer une économie solide sur la
spéculation puis qu'il y a des chanceux
qui sont sortis au bon moment il faut
que tu as des comme je disais tantôt
faut revenir à l'analyse fondamentale de
ce qui est produit dans l'économie de
quoi on a besoin collectivement puis
comment on investit dans certains
secteurs les crypto-monnaies comme je le
disais j'aime bien la technologie du
blockchain en dessous qui
qui certifie bien les choses bien les
choses quoi que l'aspect environnemental
est assez c'est difficile je pense que
l'an passé le Bitcoin a valu la
consommation de l'Argentine
[Musique]
ce serait dans le top 30 des pays du
monde en fait c'est le Bitcoin est un
pays en terme de consommation d'énergie
parce que chaque transaction prend
énormément de besoin de pouvoir de
computing power et cette énergie là
c'est l'équivalent d'un pays en fait
afin de l'année donc ça c'est un autre
aspect
les crypto ont été plus populaires avec
les jeunes qui trouvent ça bien cool
puis la finance décentralisée soyez
peut-être quelque chose de poétique
là-dedans mais quand tu es jeune que tu
es environnementaliste puis que tu
traites sur le crypto sur les
crypto-monnaies il y a quelque chose de
contradictoire parce que c'est vraiment
pas un outil qui est très
environnemental sur le plan de la
protection de l'environnement c'est pas
très bon
la crypto
cracher en 24 heures à peu près passer
de 60 mettons le Bitcoin a passé de 60
000 60 plus que 60 000 comme
ça mais en 24 heures ça passait de 60000
à 30000 puis
je veux dire tu dors le mettons que tu
dors cette nuit-là
dessus puis là ok là tu vois il y a une
drop qui appelle ça des ouais un Noël
qui décide de son stock ça aussi c'est
un interface de Bitcoin il contrôlé par
quelques grosses
c'est très opaque et puis les réseaux
qui préfèrent de loin les
crypto-monnaies si les réseaux criminels
qui savent que c'est tout de suite et
qui connaissent les Wells
mais c'est il y a quelque chose de
malsain là-dedans moi qu'un outil
financier se vendent de son opacité je
sais que ça va mal finir si c'est pas
transparent parce que quelque chose qui
devrait l'être qui l'est pas
transparentes
dans leur les banques on les connaît
très bien une volonté c'est de faire du
rendement puis plus d'argent
que ça puis les banques par contre ont
embarqué un petit peu dans les cryptos
parce qu'il voulait avoir la cool donc
des produits en crypto je pense qu'ils
vont vite se calmer c'est le fondateur
mode mais à mode d'un produit utile plus
que la mode d'une mode passagère puis
comme je disais tantôt encore une fois
je pense que le bloc change c'est une
belle avancée technologique pour en
crypter des choses mais l'utilisation
qu'on a fait dans une crypto monnaie je
vois pas l'utilité sociale à long terme
de ça parce que les banques centrales
bientôt vont en avoir une monnaie
numérique basée sur le Fiat le mot latin
qui veut dire confiance sur le Fiat des
banques centrales il va avoir une
monnaie numérique aussi
utile ou en cryptique
que les crypto monnaie disons privés
actuelles donc il y aura plus aucun
intérêt de détenir le Bitcoin pour
quelques usages que ce soit
à part certains réseaux peut-être qui
veulent encore être anonymes mais c'est
pas je pense qu'il faut pas baser le
développement d'une économie sur les
réseaux qui veulent rester anonyme
mais donc tu es
un jeune débutant
dans mon coeur
[Rires]
tu commences pour la première fois de ta
vie à avoir de l'argent en surplus
puis tu commences à penser à ta retraite
puis
c'est où tu investi dans un climat comme
actuel mais le mot clé d'investissement
c'est toujours diversification parce que
c'est très rare que tout bouge ensemble
la corrélation qu'on appelle entre les
classes d'actifs donc les actions ont
une classe d'actif la bourse les
obligations les produits de taux
d'intérêt c'est une classe d'actif
l'immobilier s'en est une qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle le privé aussi c'est des
compagnies qui sont pas encore en bourse
mais que tu peux acheter et puis faire
croître il y a des infrastructures il y
a un aéroport des autoroutes à pH tout
ça donc le fait diversifier un
portefeuille
c'est la meilleure garantie que tu auras
pas de grandes chutes de toutes les
classes ensemble
le problème c'est de mettre ses yeux
dans le même panier ce qui est ce qui
adore un stock en particulier qui met
toute leur argent là-dedans c'est stock
Mantes est très heureux mais il échange
de descendre des risques de descendre
aussi donc pour les professionnels de la
finance là il y a tout le temps les
diversification à l'esprit même si même
si tu gères juste un portefeuille
d'action tu vas diversifier les titres
dedans plusieurs l'idéal c'est d'avoir
un portefeuille qui diversifié dans
chaque claque dans chaque classe d'actif
pardon et entre les classes d'actifs
aussi
pour les particuliers
un gros fond comme la Caisse de dépôt a
des actions puis des obligations mais il
y a aussi accès à beaucoup d'immobilier
puis de travailler
pour les particuliers c'est souvent
actions et obligations c'est le fameux
portefeuille typique 60 40 60 % d'action
40% d'obligation
de plus en plus il se diversifie dans
d'autres classes d'actifs aussi ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il y a des classes
d'actifs privées comme le privé puis
l'immobilier qui sont de plus en plus
accessibles à travers certains produits
même pour les particuliers qui veulent
en mettre dans leur portefeuille alors
qu'à base de réservé aux grands fonds de
pension qui achetaient un centre d'achat
puisqu'il détenait d'être plus en plus
de produits qui permettent à des
particuliers comme mes parents au mois
de
d'avoir accès à un portefeuille très
diversifié c'est solidaire
à savoir dans quelle proportion ça
dépend de tes objectifs acheter un
bateau dans un an ou tu veux juste payer
l'université à tes enfants dans 30 ans
ça dépend de ton âge aussi évidemment
quelqu'un qui est rendu à 80 ans devrait
être un peu moins à la bourse mais un
peu plus dans des produits stables alors
que quelqu'un qui a 25 ans peut
peut-être prendre un peu plus de risques
dans des produits qui fluctuent un peu
plus comme la bourse parce qu'on disait
tantôt sur le long terme la bourse monte
donc si tu as 40 ans d'épargne devant
toi puis d'investissement tu peux te
permettre d'en mettre un peu plus à la
Bourse que quelqu'un qui est déjà
retraité puis qui vite s'y rendre qui
veut pas perdre 20%
donc les professionnels les
planificateurs financiers vont regarder
tout ça et les objectifs l'horizon ton
âge tes revenus etc mais le mot clé
c'est diversification il faut toujours
être diversifié concentré tes épingles
dans un produit ou dans un titre c'est
très très risqué puis les personnes qui
va conseiller ça mais si mettons
toutes mes économies sont dans
réel ou c'est limitant est-ce que c'est
mettre toutes ces données
peut être justement à x% en action x%
d'obligation puis comme je le disais de
plus en plus il y a des produits qui se
créent dans les classes privées donc un
jour un réel pour avoir des actions des
obligations de l'immobilier des
infrastructures et tout ça donc le réel
c'est un produit c'est un fond qui lui
peut être
qui lui fait
qui lui peut être très diversifié c'est
ça L'Oréal c'est un outil mais qui à
l'intérieur peut avoir plein d'affaires
dedans ça m'a pas empêché de faire un
bon petit saut dernièrement quand j'ai
regardé l'État
qui est exceptionnel en 2022
le premier trimestre jusqu'à fin juin
moi j'ai 52 ans comme je disais ça fait
25 ans je suis en finance j'ai jamais vu
un début d'année aussi mauvais de deux
classes d'actifs en même temps
d'habitude quand la bourse baisse les
obligations tiennent le fort ou quand
les taux d'intérêt monte très fort les
obligations baissent une relation
inverse mais la bourse monte un petit
peu en général donc il y a pas une
corrélation parfaite entre les deux
classes d'activités cette année les deux
ont craché en même temps la Bourse s'est
rendue à -20 les obligations seront déjà
moins 10 en même temps donc il y avait
nulle part où aller se cacher
un bon vieux cash ce qui avait de
l'argent
ou ceux qui ont eu la chance encore une
fois ou la lucidité de tout vendre avant
que ça se mette à baisser puis qui
restait en cache en toute matelas ou à
caisse pop donc cette c'est rare très
rare en compte c'est très rare mais la
classe d'activité si on prend action
obligation puis en caisse l'argent
puis que les choses vont repartir puis
même entre les banques
City il s'entendent même pas là dessus
sur la croissance le bas de la bourse et
tout ça donc ça demeure il y a pas de
cristal non non
un jour il va vite dépasser les masques
en richesse là aussi si tu pouvais avoir
raison dans toutes les décisions
d'investissement en un mois tu es
l'homme le plus riche de la terre
mais ça existe pas il y en a qui ont
passé l'aide puis qui
est très difficile à prévoir mais la
base c'est de rester diversifié puis de
si tu as encore de l'horizon évidemment
c'est ceux qui sont ceux qui sont très
âgés puis qui ont plus de patience c'est
ça mais
si tu as encore un horizon faut pas
vendre après un crash parce que du
cristalise ta perte 10 20 ans 30 ans
d'horizon la bourse va remonter à ce
niveau là
c'est ça l'idéal c'est de vendre au
sommet puis de racheter au cru mais il y
a personne qui peut faire ça en année
après année chaque année il y a un
gestionnaire étoile que tout les bonnes
les bons coups au bon moment puis c'est
très rare que c'est le même gestionnaire
étoile 28 donc
une petite aspect chance en finance
quand même évidemment en général c'est
une bonne gestion du risque puis qu'une
bonne diversification puis une bonne
équipe sérieuse sur le long terme ça se
voit tu peux différencier des
gestionnaires de l'autre mais il y a des
coups de chance que tu as dans certaines
années que tu as pas trois ans de suite
mais en général la qualité d'un
gestionnaire va se voir dans le long
terme plus que chaque année
on dirait que on dirait que ça
m'inquiète on dirait que je t'inquiétais
comme je disais tantôt le tissu
économique du Québec fait qu'on est
chanceux d'être ici on va s'en sortir
mieux qu'ailleurs je pense grâce à trop
tout piliers collectif qui est très fort
qui est une grande part d'économie mais
on pourra pas se sauver des
soubresauts de l'économie surtout
américaine qui est juste à côté puis eux
je te dirai qu'ils sont un peu plus dans
le pétrin que nous autres puis on va
parler beaucoup la pandémie mais c'est
quoi l'impact
de la gare Ukraine sur l'économie un peu
moins qu'en Europe en fait la guerre en
Ukraine l'invasion l'Ukraine ça a
beaucoup augmenté l'inflation mondiale
parce que le pétrole est très très enjeu
là-dedans ça a augmenté les risques de
famine bien dépays développés qui
dépendaient du grain de l'Ukraine de la
Russie aussi au Québec au Canada
on est beaucoup moins relié à l'économie
russe on a des sources d'énergie propre
à nous on voulait pas du on peut on
brûle pas du pétrole russe de pétrole
russe ici sauf que j'imagine que si le
prix du pétrole augmente globalement il
y a augmente partout le prix est mondial
donc c'est le prix à la pompe ici on le
voit même si on produit du pétrole au
Canada et puis on pourrait bien se dire
pourquoi on le prend pas en cours
mais le prix est mondialisé du pétrole
et donc notre impact économique qui est
indirect à travers l'inflation puis la
hausse du prix l'essence et tout mais en
Europe il y a des impacts directs
l'Allemagne avait une bonne partie je
parle tout le temps l'Allemagne mais
encore une fois l'Allemagne avait une
bonne partie de son énergie qui venait
de la Russie en Finlande c'était presque
un pourcentage extrêmement élevé
d'énergie qui venait de la Russie donc
eux des impacts directs pas simplement
indirect à travers l'inflation mais ici
on a la chance entre guillemets de pas
être un grand partenaire économique de
Russie puis de l'Ukraine
donc encore une fois on est chanceux
dans une région géographique éloignée
parce que plus tu es proche du pays où
ça brosse plus tu avais des chances
d'avoir des liens économiques proches
puis l'Europe de l'Est la partie plus
orientale de l'Europe
occidentale des anciens pays du nom
soviétique qui sont maintenant un peu
plus dans l'Union européenne c'est eux
qui souffrent le plus de ça sur le plan
alimentaire c'est des pays en
développement qui dépendent de ces
grains là qui sont encore pris en
Ukraine puis que la Russie black c'est
pas c'est pas très gai pour bien des
pays mais encore une fois je suis encore
optimiste que ça va se régler plutôt que
tard parce que les
pays s'organisent plus vite là pour
essayer de limiter le prix auquel la
Russie peut vendre son pétrole entre
autres parce que la Russie Finance SA
guerre avec le pétrole il faut encore
des milliards chaque jour avec ça donc
les pays occidentaux veulent se
s'entendre sur le fait de pas payer plus
cher que X le prix du pétrole russe pour
arrêter de financer le regard
d'avoir un consensus dans tous les pays
pour dire ok on fait ça c'est facile
pour nous on a Hydro-Québec au Québec
puis on a le pétrole en général au
Canada mais les pays qui dépend de
l'énergie russe pour leur voiture ou
leur maison c'est très difficile de dire
ok
[Musique]
c'est complexe mais ça monte encore une
fois que
la démocratie c'est le fun
c'est fou que un gars instable viennent
bouleverser la planète puis je parle là
je parle du président russe on avait
président américain à peu près instable
aussi puisqu'il a fait endommage qui
vont durer longtemps c'est incroyable à
quel point quoi que les c'est une
démocratie mais est un peu malade un peu
défaillante pour avoir élu un gars de
même c'est ça me dépasse mais c'est non
mais c'est capoté
cette idée-là
un petit peu dans un état de paranoïa
puis en tout cas puisse décider ok on va
là puis on suit du monde puis je dis à
des humains dans les tuer d'autres
humains puis d'autres encore
c'est pas comme
on n'avons pas un commando assassiné
Poutine d'un petit demain matin à côté
dans le sens que c'est peut-être ça
venait de l'intérieur parce qu'il y a
des risques qui sont pas très durer ce
qui se passe là j'ai pas commencé à
faire là mais une des options que les
politologues disent très possible c'est
que de l'intérieur il s'organise
pourtant c'est Poutine qui a perdu
[ __ ]
la désinformation qui donne à son propre
peuple pour être encore soutenu ça
marche de moins en moins plus en plus de
risques qui savent que il y a du
mensonge au pied carré pas mal donc ça
pourra pas durer éternellement
on l'espère les problèmes c'est qu'ils
sont armés avec des choses assez
dangereuses c'est ça
Poutine
avec Julien Touareg ça reste j'ai pas
lui qui va poser sur le bouton là
quelqu'un qui va devoir poser sur le
bouton
au nom de quelqu'un qui ouais qui est
sauté Vladimir Poutine peut pas décider
j'ouvre la valise puis je peux
que plein de choses se fasse en même
temps mais c'est à moins que tout le
monde est vraiment peur de dire ce qu'il
pense réellement quand on entend
d'autres
tes membres de la haute société russe ou
du gouvernement russe il y en a plein
qui sont beaucoup plus
vous avez vu il y en avait un public
dans un espèce de réunion où il
cuisinait petit conseiller qui a pas été
là mais c'est on voit que le monsieur va
pas bien
de se dire que il y a une guerre en ce
moment en Europe qui
Ève c'est une ville qui brasse laisse
une ville de Party c'est une ville
dynamique c'est pas genre
le fin fond de la Russie là métropole
active avec des arts puis ça fait penser
un peu la guerre des Balkans quelques
années là
il y avait eu les Olympiques là il y a
pas longtemps avant pour envoyer des
belles images c'est une ville avancée
comme ici puis pendant le temps après
c'était la désolation totale parce qu'il
y avait une guerre civile incroyable
mais
[Musique]
ça me fait plaisir toujours plaisir
ou stressant ou je peux trouver mais je
pense qu'on a bien bien résumé bien
vulgarisé
que tu voulais faire un album je pense
que c'était avant avant je sais pas
calme avant un âge
ça fait trois ans tu es rendu à quel
trade sur l'album 35 ans que ma mère m'a
entendu
futur mais plus grands succès mais non
il faut que je le fasse un jour quand
j'étais jeune j'avais pas
les couilles de le faire là j'ai plus le
temps de le faire c'est un mélange des
deux mais oui un de ces jours je dois
publier mes compositions juste pour le
fan des publier mais ce serait pas pour
en vivre en faire carrière mais ça va
venir parce que j'ai trop de stocks que
je partage c'est pas obligé d'être
plus gros que t'asseoir un piano une
journée jouer en plus que j'ai plein
d'amis qui ont des studios qui me disent
viens dis-nous des apps on fait des
affaires et s'il est pas parfait ou
c'est juste
parfait
un autre après oui mais je le ferai pour
le fun Radio
j'ai plus d'orgueil quand j'avais 18 ans
mes composent je voulais pas faire jouer
à personne de peur qu'il trouve pas ça
aussi bon que moi il y a quelque chose
qui marche pas mais là ce serait ça me
ferait juste plaisir de partager ça ça
va se faire
des
prestations
d'un peuple j'étais au piano on a fait
le tour du Québec avec Salomé Leclerc je
rentre d'Arran qui était dans le groupe
puis évidemment Alexandre Belliard qui
chantait ses textes puis j'ai accompagné
une coupe de fois d'autres dans des
spectacles bénéfices ça fait comme ça
mais c'est plus dans un réseau d'amis je
peux aller
mais c'est ça c'est pour les femmes ou
pour des causes que je le fais pour
l'instant mais j'aimerais ça partager
mon stock aussi
il soit sorti l'album 3 ans parce que là
forcément deux fois par an
[Rires]
ouais c'est ça exactement
et merci beaucoup à bientôt
si vous voulez plus de contenus
excellents comme ce que vous venez
d'entendre allez sur le pitoyante vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
ça trop dollars par mois et vous avez
les podcasts en avance ça veut dire que
les premiers de votre groupe d'amis
avoir écouté les podcasts puis vous
allez avoir pouvoir avoir une avance
quand vous allez dire la dynamique entre
les amis tout le temps d'avoir une
avance sur les autres
mais avec pétrie tu as une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que là le podcast fini vous voulez
nous entendre jaser davantage on fait
des encore moins de filtres après chaque
podcast avec le on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
chier Nicole non Nicole il pue là
maintenant
on parle de la conversion qu'on vient
d'avoir mais ça si vous voulez avoir
accès à ce
heureusement pour nous malheureusement
pour vous c'est exclusif sur PQ